hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to vacate the room now this
is a virtual reality experience is
supposed to be like one of the escape
rooms that I've played numerous times
that are you Tolima dan black but this
one's baby unity whole point
ha ha boink there we go oh wow man Wow I
am cramped in this room how did I get in
here why can't I see anything why am i
trapped freedom please okay woah what is
that up there
Can I grab this whoa what is this it
looks like a fuse but I'm not I'll
represent sure so this is supposed to be
exactly like a room escape oh good I
need this oh [ __ ] how am I supposed to
maneuver this no power try this oh okay
but there's a lock over there okay so
this is obviously a fuse or something of
the like so I'm gonna put this down
there for a second don't roll off
no no ah dammit god dammit stop give me
thank you okay you don't roll stay right
there okay it's got no oh no okay you
stay there
alright hang on I got to get this
flashlight a little better on my my
other hand Oh cold delicious refreshing
choke I love a good choke first thing in
the morning hello whoa hi are you
watching me better not be
I'm watching this guy I don't know who
you is but you might be the game
developer so hello [ __ ] I made it face
through the floor okay anything on the
back of this and anything on the front
of this no but this is really cool
cuz I gotta like explore everything oh
hi mow the lawn man an awesome movie
about enjoying virtual reality while
working in the garden Stephen King Wow
hello Wow well [ __ ] whoa hey buddy
alright do that out here well catch hope
catch a point oh man that's so weird
virtual reality to the max Brooke okay
so this goes on what there's a number
panel over there whoa hey how's it going
buddy do I need to scan that QR code I
don't think I need to do that
this game all right this goes somewhere
where the [ __ ] does this go crumpled
pieces of paper nothing of note there
here's a piece of paper all right all
this stuff books movies and even music I
guess I used them as some kind of escape
the page number 2 ha here we go oh wait
it's the same thing on either side okay
never mind but that's note number one or
note number two okay so I'll set you
over here here's know number one okay
I'm still here even if I came here on my
own and skate seems not to be impossible
anymore oh not to be possible anymore
who was I to think that I was actually
reading words correctly high from the
maker of loud mountains Diller Hill hope
oh there we go
ah Spiller Hill no one will listen okay
what about you who the wrong Ringo Ringo
of course my favorite movie Ringo
hi okay so I got that I got the fuse and
I turn this on anyway what's in here
nothing ah there we go
I found you okay I got this too now I
got two of these things but I still need
to figure out how to pull them in there
cuz I need a key for that I believe who
me just right there ah there you are
hello
can I get you thank you okay so I got
another one of these boink
leave those there okay something to do
with this hey [ __ ] you I'm just an old
man trying to hobble my way back through
time so poor I gave a [ __ ] Wow getting
behind the monitor whoo hello found you
okay and do that I've got these you know
get that choke out of here okay I did I
did nothing cuz I still have no power
man I'm lost what is that oh oh oh
there's something back there
it's a code one for 504 okay one for 504
one for 504 no nothing maybe on this one
1/4 504 I don't feel like I'm pressing
them
oh wait what's in the way what's in here
and there's something in here what's in
here
ooh there's something down here hang on
trash but this what is this
whoo that don't look good I can't read
that numbers numbers that numbers I
can't quite tell what that is what is
that
that's not letters it's a love letter to
my lovely wife oh hello how long have
you been there I don't recall you being
there but I found you okay well I found
that which might mean that I've missed
other things what could I possibly
missed I've been pretty thorough I don't
think there's anything down there unless
there is then I'm an idiot
oh there oh I haven't looked there I
can't believe that I must have look
there I gotta spin my way to break free
cuz I got tangled ah
I hope I'm spinning the right way oh
well whatever [ __ ] okay I'll deal with
it
doink okay chee cheong all right wow
that is a lot more colors than I thought
there was gonna be but I think I got
them all
wink okay so that got blue light over
there and then I got the rest of them
over here get out of the way mouse I've
got a mystery to solve
Bobolink oh we're doing so good Oh
boink okay on roll baby oh boy okay yeah
boink and last one which amazingly have
found them all already huh Miami oh we
got power okay that makes sense because
I wasn't able to do anything before okay
let's see if the computer will turn on
hello what's going on it seems as if I'm
locked in this room how will I get out
maybe I left a clue somewhere
hope I didn't discard it well that would
be horribly stupid wouldn't it
and I use this at all no hope I didn't
discard it you talking about this
freaking nature here I guess I'm done
with this alright it was nice knowing
you thank you have a go one okay 1 4 5 0
4 so 1 4 5 0 4 yes ok give me this I
need you now I need you now
Wow ok how to escape find the keys find
the fuses find the letters climb out
question mark ok and it's a drawing of
what I can only assume is freedom
alright here we go huh blowing huh
blowing I need this whoa all right what
do we got
whoa that looks uncomfortable and
cramped oh boy hi how's it going I don't
know where I am in my room but it
probably doesn't look good ok and
another note over here I can't grab that
one it's too far below the floor I'll
just read it from here all the time
wherever I did not want to see anybody
now I want to see somebody but I don't
think I can
that's too bad for you douche you made
your choice now sleep in your bed I
think this has got to go here whew and
then I'll boink yeah what does that do
what did that do I don't know what that
do what did that do
Oh No well oh here we go
ooh is this a thing didn't look like a
thing but this might be a thing that I
need to do do okay hang on wait no
nothing there
wait is there something there woo wait a
minute wait a minute wait a minute
there's something here save code two
seven eight four whoa that is hidden -
seven eight four no I must not have been
in - eight seven four probably
ah okay all right okay
who is this Who I am who as I exit past
nice Mundy past alright I have to stop
hiding myself the real life is going on
outside I have to get out I couldn't
agree more
I couldn't agree more man okay so whoa
hey what the [ __ ] are you doing
oooh that's where the handle comes in
okay hang on
wait oh god damn it with this I did it I
found my way out here I want to skip
through them I just have to take off the
VR headset Wow handy-dandy or [ __ ] tips
breathe oh hey my god it's like magic
take my choke oh [ __ ] yeah okay but I
think that is actually it so that is
whoa hey hey guys that is VR escape the
room that was actually a really cool
experience I had a lot of fun with that
it was amazing because I had to like
literally crawl and actually physically
explore my of environment and that was
part of the game that was like the first
game that has made physical interaction
in the environment the actual gameplay
which is amazing because it actually
takes advantage of what the vibe is
about so that was really cool but I want
to know what you think of it let me know
in the comments down below and thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
how about we're back on the tip of your
giant nose Oh like a butterfly just like
a bean